what's up everyone we have the Samsung
Galaxy a54 one of Samsung's more
affordable phones that's new to their
lineup Bobby went out and tested its
cameras you can check that out on the
top right here to see how this performs
and you'd be surprised but for now we'll
be putting it through the gaming
Gauntlet of Genji impact pubg mobile Cod
mobile and honkai stereo to see if this
phone can perform Under Pressure except
for pubg mobile though you guys have
asked for it on a number of occasions so
we will be testing pubg for how smooth
the frame rate is performance wise the
Samsung that we are using has a xenos
1380 a Mali g68 MP5 for its GPU 8 gigs
of RAM 128 gigs of storage and
everything plays out on a 120hz Super
AMOLED 6.4 inch screen with a 5 000
milliamp hour battery okay so before we
start the test let's do a baseline check
for the temperatures let's check the
front and we are at 28 ish on the front
right now we'll see 28 in the higher 27s
and on the back we are running at 27-ish
28 ish which you know isn't too bad and
also we're at 100 battery so that's cool
all right so now we're in Genji impact
let's check our settings real quick
here we go and Graphics okay so right
now we are on the highest for everything
60 FPS which is the highest the phone
can handle or rather the game will allow
the phone to handle and everything with
high even motion Bliss and high ntl 78a
and I think we are good to go so let's
just walk around in Azuma and see how
this thing runs but so far it's looking
pretty good I mean honestly the the game
looks amazing on this display
check out her character real quick isn't
her model and she's looking really good
even like the glow and everything on her
sword is amazing
this is actually panning out to be quite
fun like sprinting sofa everything is
looking pretty all right there are no
obvious family jobs or anything I don't
think there's anything so far
it will just be able to frame stop doing
here and there but it's honestly barely
noticeable
and let's jump put no action to it
so far it's doing pretty all right
it does feel a little bit janky but you
know it's not super obvious all right so
far I think the phone is handling it
pretty well there is a bit of frame
start during and a bit of Fairway drops
here and there but honestly more
manageable compared to other phones that
we've reviewed in the past so with that
let's move on to exploration and some
combat
oh yep oh boy okay
so yeah as you can see just shifting
around it's
pretty janky again this is on the
highest set things with everything
turned on high and turned on so
oh Lord all right
let's try to move around but the jaw
this is pretty good I mean the game
looks beautiful on this display I'm not
complaining about that
but what I will say is that when it
comes to these kind of texturage
environments the phone does struggle a
little bit
that's all right
damn it it's cool
can you get up yeah boy
yeah as you can see it does
the frame rate is dropping quite a bit
come on come on come on get up oh come
on okay just a little bit
[Music]
let's see what's up
really hurts oh I can't see anything oh
boy
[Applause]
and then I'll be as you can see
so with that combat encounter you can
tell that you know you can get a game
out of this you can play this but the
thing is that at the cost of a lot of
frame start doing a lot of frame rate
drops even with you know just dribbling
the camera around on the character it's
just yeah you can see that it does start
a little bit so it's not super
consistent
even just exploring you know it does
feel kind of junky you're not going to
get that full 60 FPS it's not going to
be like super smooth
so yeah that's the thing
all right let's just do one more before
we go to these spiral this
oh yeah yeah oh boy okay
so yeah okay thank you still where's
that other himicho all right so spiral
this time of course you know there's
less things for the phone to deal with
since we are in an indoor area so let's
just see how this goes
yes let's just hit him with a quick alt
View
yeah so I I guess with
this kind of area is expirables and
everything you're going to have a pretty
you're going to be doing pretty much
fine actually
it'll be you're gonna be doing okay
yeah you could be doing fine yeah this
is actually pretty smooth compared to
the open wall stuff yeah this is great
[Music]
let's go there's one more let's take out
this fellow
real quick
before he jumps you jump oh okay we got
him all nice let's move the other side
[Music]
okay it's getting going on
there we go okay so I think we did
pretty well for that I think there's
just an issue when it comes to you know
exploration and whatnot so let's just
check temperatures real quick 41 degrees
wow okay I did not expect it to get that
high but when you're on the top half on
you that I guess that's where the chip
is I mean that's where the ship is
always at anyway so yeah it's yeah this
this this part is hot this is actually
pretty hot but everything else is pretty
all right even the sides still feel
pretty cool let's check the front
40 years 40 39 yeah this thing is by
it's it should be running high but it
doesn't feel that hard
so yeah this actually the phone is doing
pretty well okay besides the exploration
bits so with that let's just move on to
the next game and we'll discuss this
more in the conclusion next game is Hong
Kai stereo let's move on to Hong Kai
stereo but before that let's check out
temperatures we are also currently at 94
the entire session of like what 15
minutes took about six percent so you do
the maths let's just check temperatures
real quick
34 the oh the phone has cooled down
quite a bit pretty quickly
wow okay all right all right all right
all right let's check the pack
the background A35 and where the chip is
at it's about
38-ish that's uh oh okay so this handles
heat pretty well let's see how he
handles honkai stereo
and so now that we are here let's just
check our settings real quick
and settings
here we are very high 60 FPS the highest
the phone and the game can allow us
share the qualities in high everything's
on very high ta yep we are all good and
let's just look at the details and she's
looking
pretty good actually I mean it's
actually running a lot smoother than
gentian which is surprising but also not
that surprising even how konkai style
looks like
okay so we will be doing a lot of story
stuff but I will be playing a lot of
herder stuff okay so now we're in
herta's office we're going to be playing
some simulated universe and let's just
get into it let's just enter
and oh nice all right so far the game is
running pretty smooth I'd say
even so much so competition but let's
see how it does like with combat let's
see
um we're gonna need Rosario wreck there
we go
ah okay let's see all right so who's
first oh sample okay
yo yeah so animations and all are pretty
smooth so far
from what I'm seeing
all right so let's just go with a blast
okay second half of the battle
sample goes out windshield okay let's
see works right okay it's a bit janky
right now a little bit janky foreign
it does like a little bit but other than
that it's fine I believe
okay let's get in the elite time
no we don't
but I think like with japarts
um I think we may have some issues with
that one because it's all things there
is a lot going on in the ultimate
all right
all right let's go with marches all
right
and then okay let's see how it goes like
uh see how it goes
it's pretty smooth so far I mean it's
not like 360 FPS but whatever
all right let's just keep hitting never
mind
okay hit him with the ulti
and is it janky yeah yeah it is yeah it
stopped us quite a bit
security broke that all right now the
parts all the coin dampens
okay things happen already it's fine
but yeah let's just see how old these
work okay as you can see you know it's
already janky
oh
all right let's see okay yeah
what else cream stop doing I mean again
we are playing on everything the highest
with 60 FPS so we are kind of we are
really putting the phone to its cases
okay what let's go
that should be it nice
so thought so far I mean it is doing
pretty all right I believe
I am a little bit bothered by the frame
start doing but other than that
it runs okay I mean if you lower down
the settings and whatever it will run
okay
it's just let's just ignore her there
real quick and then just get straight
into combat
okay hold on
so when it comes to like exploring
anything you know you will still see
that frame start three and whatnot and
when it comes to combat you will still
see the same thing so like I mean honkai
stereo does need someone when it comes
to these newer models I mean again this
phone is still pretty much new and so is
Stereo so competitively in everything
and also you know we are putting all the
settings on the highest so it will take
some time
to really get this phone properly
compatible
samples should be you should do it there
you go
and oh still not done yet are we still
running are we done yeah we're done
nice
all right let's party now again again as
you can see it's not the smoothest but
it will do
oh it's already smoothing out a little
bit so oh it's not too bad
but it took some time to do that okay
let's get some posting out
also I may skip ahead to the end of the
boss fight because this boss fight is a
real grind
yeah this is gonna take a while oh boy
but so far okay
I'm stuttering
okay so I think we want to be able to
take down our first boss
all right that's one down three for me
drop right there
let's get back
[Music]
oh boy
it should be easy after this all right
he's pretty low as well let's just hit
him with the one two
there we go samples all key
and now with him alone all damage to the
school Street dude
there we go
all right everyone's got Shields
and I think this one should seal the
deal I think
let's just go for it
there we go yeah he does okay so with
that as you can see Hong Kai style rail
still needs to put up a little bit
optimizing for the a54
so let's just check temperatures real
quick
we are at 40 44 439 here 37ish
it's doing okay actually it's not as
tall as Kenshin but I think it's about
the same as the engine actually
all right 42 at the top where the chip
is at and as we go down
39 38 37 36 35
yeah so it's actually a pretty good form
when it comes to Thermal management it's
just that when it comes to games like
the engine and honkai man okay it's
gonna be a bit to talk about there when
it comes to Performance in the
conclusion so with that let's move on to
the next game Call of Duty mobile
before we get into the next game this
channel is supported by Brands who help
us improve our content and keep us going
so stay around for this sponsored
message meet this eyeball 15 game out
from MSI check out this translucent
material design that not only looks good
but feels good thanks to its Ultra
lightweight chassis at only 1.98
kilograms give yourself the upper Edge
in gaming with its blazing fast
performance powered by the latest 12 gen
Intel Core i7h Series processor and
Nvidia RTX 4000 series gpus and they
immersed with its nahibi twin speaker
sound system that provides an auditory
Feast like no other for more details
check out msi.com alright so we are
heart of the heels of Hong Kai stereo we
are at 85 let's check our temperatures
real quick
and yeah this thing is handling heat
pretty well it's dissipating it very
efficiently
surprising huh all right let's check the
back
33 34 and the top it was like 14 minutes
ago
wow it's all bad yeah
surprising stuff all right so with that
let's move on to Call of Duty okay so
now that we're at the menu the major
looks really good as always and I you
know the menu is very smooth so far
she's looking beautiful as always let's
check out set these real quick audio
Graphics we are on high graphic quality
very high frame rate and multiplayer
everything is turned on except for these
things which I can't touch so let's just
uh pre-load our cache I'll save the cash
okay the Shader preload is almost done
and you know I'll use any available tool
I have to smoothen up my game so we're
going to restart the game real quick and
then we'll get into a match so so far
it's looking pretty good it's not janky
laws I mean it's pretty smooth call it
no juicy isn't a demanding game and
oh escort looks pretty good
very nice all right let's just keep
moving
all right I mean the size for the phone
is actually not too bad because like
oh boy okay hold on hold on hold on
let's get the guy oh
okay that's bad yeah so avoid the phone
size it's actually it's a pretty good
size I don't feel like super cramped up
or anything when I'm holding this and
like oh where is the guy at oh oh
it is a pretty good size it's not too
big it's not too small
oh
nice it's a guy on top as well
nice really good
oh boy okay I'm gonna need to reload
real quick where's my reload button okay
it's over here that is great okay okay I
know I know oh there's one guy behind us
okay we are dominating here right now
okay okay
let's go okay EMP
it's fine
okay okay we're doing good we're doing
good we're doing a good video okay let's
move on to the Sun real quick and yeah
this this is actually working out pretty
well
and it's got Dogs Out
uh it's running very smooth I believe
there's someone over there
where we grew up
nice
okay I'm fine I need it okay so now we
have Bears over here
I can't oh I didn't get him through the
okay never mind it's fine it's just
shorty M I believe he should still be
inside
on top he's not here anymore okay that's
a good thing all right this one
of these small
all right two so far controls an 18 fuel
Pretty Natural on this thing
I mean it's not super janky and it's not
like super cramped up like I said again
so ergonomics wise it's doing pretty
well
let's push into this building and get
into the Norman Zone it's just steal
this real quickly here like real quick
like right there right there
oh yeah that's a good one I believe okay
oh okay final kill all right so there's
a whole game and honestly I'll say oh
invest here okay but yeah before I say
that dream it's been a very smooth
experience playing with the a54 the
qualities and so far even with the
highest of things and yeah let's check
out temperatures real quick
and we are currently at 36 37ish
35 it's doing pretty all right let's
check back
[Music]
it's actually doing pretty decent it's
even below 40. wow yeah and honestly the
phone is still comfortable to hold in
hand so
oh yeah
pretty good with this uh Samsung all
right with that let's move on to our
next game and our final game
pubg mobile
okay so we are heart of the heels of
Call of Duty mobile we are currently 82
and let's check our temperatures real
quick we literally just came off by the
way so
we're at 37 right now on the top 36 35
and it keeps getting lower all right not
too bad for the front let's check the
back
34 33 to 34 at the top
35 36 wow 37 it went like two degrees
and like basically a whole degree or two
in like a span of like a second I mean
it's been less than a minute
since we came off Call of Duty so yeah
it's doing really well all right let's
play pubg mobile again we are here for
the smoothest frame rate as many if you
want so let's do that
okay it's another way in pubg mobile
let's check also things real quick
settings and graphics and audio here we
go so we're on smooth right now we're
going to be playing the highest
frame rate classic color style and
dealership two times and yeah I believe
this should be good so expecting great
things when we start a match
you do want a graphics you want a
smoothness and it's looking pretty
smooth it's it's very smooth actually so
let's just move in and see where we're
gonna land I believe I want to learn in
of course
let's do just that and we are jumping
okay looking pretty smooth so far no
noticeable family jobs or anything it's
playing pretty well all right let's just
keep moving
and as you can see you know it's looking
pretty old it's looking pretty okay draw
distance and everything is looking
pretty much fine and perfect I believe
you can aim downwards and hit straight
into pachinki
obviously you get guns you get
everything and so far this fall has been
very smooth oh actually you know let me
just hit up the church real quick
at the top of the hill
I should be able to reach that
I believe
I can't reach that I okay I can't but
never mind I'm still alive it's fine
it's fun it's one that's one that's one
that's one we are recordings at 60 FPS
once again
so
this is doing okay I don't know how much
I can do with a nine millimeter
but we shall see hopefully I can run
into at least a shotgun at least a
shotgun come on
check upstairs
oh boy
okay that was me
come on Close Quarters
let's go
where is this guy let's kill him
it should be on here get in the car
oh boy
okay that was bad but
I used to be like you're doing fine
you're doing fine
going to be coming up pretty soon I
believe
oh but oh okay that was nice
let you down
get Scooby baby
okay there's one more person out here
somewhere on here
okay we are doing we're doing okay
oh boy okay
foreign
I mean okay honestly recording stuff and
then playing at the same time is a lot
harder than it looks
so the fact that I'm getting kills is a
miracle at this point
okay I gotta hit shot on
I'm gonna kill that real quick this guy
is pretty good he knows what he's doing
I should be rushing him but I don't okay
you know I'm gonna run go around the
building I'm gonna flank him
okay I'm gonna flank him right now
pushing pushing pushing pushing pushing
there we go
yeah it's crude boy
get screwed
and that is how you flank
and I think it's safe enough so let's
get into prone and let's check
temperatures and if anything happens
anyone that goes through we are at 34
ish I mean we are playing on lowest of
things and we are prioritizing frame
rate frame rate has been amazing so far
yes and let's check the back
top half 36 37 very decent and as we go
down it just gets lower and lower and
lower so we are doing very well with the
fd4 right now and honestly I think you
guys can see that with any kind of
Engagement
the a54 is working and is doing the job
pretty well so with that
let's just play a bit more and then see
how it goes and if anything we'll move
on to our final
conclusion let's move this guy right
there I'm in front yep
you guys saw that too right it's not
just me playing on the signs
oh yep
going down
let's go baby okay let's not want to see
but never mind uh wrong command
and
rushed that's how you do it so to
conclude the Samsung a54 is quite the
surprise with games I Call of Duty
mobile and pubg mobile playing pretty
well and smooth even though Call of Duty
was on the highest at things I'd say you
can get a good amount of gaming out of
it with less demanding games pubg mobile
was smooth and I was winning all my
gunfights thanks to the phones
relatively good size relative to the
size of my hands of course it was a
comfortable experience though you will
be covering in speakers from time to
time it's because being on the side
right here in the case of genchin and
honkai you really need to scale down the
settings especially for honkai frame
rate drops lag and stuttering play
konkai but if you're planning to play
spiral bits for genjin for the rest of
your life this phone would do all right
but besides the more demanding games I
feel for its price point it's a decent
phone to game on with good thermal
management and size to boot I'm really
surprised with how it manages heat but
what I want to know is would you get
this let me know in the comments below
make sure to follow us on all of our
socials right here to keep up to date
with all the news and fun stuff we put
out and if you like this video consider
subscribing subscribing again maybe
hitting the like button it goes a long
way and if you want to see more stuff
check this out
[Music]
foreign